bon on a quatre minutes trente pour
répondre à tout ça je pense que je
veuille absolument dans dans mes
modestes aux activités j'en ai une qui
est d'être enseignant donc je fais un
cours à paris je suis désolé par lyon
pour des élèves ingénieurs
ça fait vingt-quatre heures et en 24
heures j'arrive à décortiquer un peu 10%
des questions qu'il ya déposé donc donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut que oui enfin ça
ça veut juste dire que pour rentrer dans
ce genre de sujet malheureusement en une
heure on va se livrer à quelques
échanges d'avis et ça ira pas beaucoup
plus loin que ça je vais faire un juste
une fin je répondrai à aucune des
questions et répondra tout en disant que
dans ce genre d'exercice prospectifs en
fait il ya une première grille de
lecture qui est extrêmement utile qui
est de séparer ceux qui dépendent ou de
skins et de ceux qui par dont ne dépend
pas de nous le lithium compte trois
proton et dans 50 ans il comptera
toujours 3 proton et il ya 50 ans il
comptait déjà trois proton et ça
changera pas le diamètre de la terre il
est ce qu'il est à peu près 13 mille
kilomètres et il n'est pas près de
changer dans les 50 ans qui viennent
donc il ya un certain nombre d'éléments
comme ça alors ça peut paraître des
banalités ce que je dis mais qui ne
changeront pas et alors dans les deux
trucs majeure qui ne changeront pas dans
les 50 ans qui viennent y est la loi de
conservation de l'énergie erec de trois
et on se rend compte quand on aborde ce
genre de problème que si on se contente
d'utiliser à son profit la loi de
conservation de l'énergie erec de 3 on
est déjà capable de faire un tri
extrêmement fort entre les diverses
options qui s'offrent à nous et très
souvent le résultat de ce tri il a une
valeur d usage qui est faible non pas
parce que le calcul est pas bon mais
parce qu'on vient heurter tout un tas de
propos qui ont été affirmés 352 x et à
force d'entendre 352 font un truc ça
devient une vérité on se pose plus à ce
moment la question oui juste pour ceux
qui comme moi ne savent pas ce que c'est
que la loi de conservation de l'énergie
un petit rappel c'est ennuyeux vous
sachiez pas ça
puisque hier soir vous étiez au 20
heures de france 2 n'en sait pas plus on
sait pas tout est la loi de conservation
du reste au 20 heures de france 2 j'ai
noté avec beaucoup d'intérêt que en
trois minutes de temps on a déploré que
les affaires d'un parapétrolier aille
plus mal pour juste derrière le sujet
d'après déploré qu' on ne fasse pas de
progrès sur la question climatique
juste après bon j'ai bien fait de venir
voilà est juste on s'est félicité du
fait que la population alors sur les
planètes qui fait toujours 13 mille
kilomètres je ne sais pas si c'était le
but donc le la loi de conservation de
l'énergie a dit un truc très simple elle
dit que dans un système clos l'énergie
se conserve et de là vous tirer une
conclusion absolument majeur qui est que
toutes énergies utilisées par les hommes
ne peut être que extraites de
l'environnement on ne peut rien faire
d'autre qu'extraire à notre profit une
énergie qui existe déjà dans
l'environnement parce que si on était
capable de faire autrement on
s'appellerait merlin l'enchanteur
ce qui n'est pas le cas et ça veut dire
par exemple que dans les énergies qui
ont été évoqués par patrick par exemple
hydrogène ya pas d'hydrogène natif sur
terre enfin quantité ridicule et donc il
faut le faire avec autre chose on peut
on sait très bien le faire et
industriels air liquide deux premiers
qui s'est extrêmement bien faire ça mais
il faut le faire avec autre chose pour
qu'à ce moment il faut avoir une analyse
en chaîne de valeur en cycle de vie pour
savoir quel est le bilan global de toute
cette affaire et extraire de l'énergie à
notre profit c'est quelque chose qui est
d'autant plus facile que la source est
concentré et pas trop difficile d'accès
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
pétrole
notre ami puyané est la reine des
énergies parce que mère nature a
concentré cette énergie en quelques
dizaines ou centaines de millions
d'années avec un rendement soit dit en
passant qui est totalement ridicule lors
de 10 - 12 et il ya car a littéralement
se baisser pour le ramasser
c'est la raison pour laquelle le coût
technique d'extraction d'un baril
désert saoudien tant que les saoudiens
nous laisse le faire c'est de l'ordre
d'une fraction de centimes par
kilowattheure est à ce prix là une
fraction de centimes par kilowattheure
est à ce prix là vous avez déjà la
fonction de stock dire que votre pétrole
vous l'avez extrême vous en servez
exactement quand vous voulez il n'y a
pas deux il ya pas de problème c'est la
raison pour laquelle on est passé des
énergies renouvelables qui étaient les
seules énergies que nous utilisions il
ya deux siècles
il ya deux siècles l'humanité c'est 100
% venaient donc pour répondre à la
question de patrick est ce que c'est
possible oui c'est possible
physiquement c'est possible on a déjà
fait est ce que c'est le confort de vie
d'aujourd'hui
jamais de la vie mais est ce que c'est
possible oui donc le on est passé de ces
énergies très diffuse donc demandant
beaucoup d'efforts pour être extraites
de l'environnement le vent le soleil etc
permettant des usages intermittents donc
la marine à voile ça arrive et quand ça
arrive et puis quand ça arrive et pas
assez vite les marins avaient scorbut à
des usages qui aujourd'hui sont
totalement pilotable est totalement
piloter et c'est ça qui fait qu'on est
capable d'organiser la société avec des
trains qui partent à l'heure quelles que
soient les conditions climatiques
donc le l'exercice auquel je vous invite
sans répondre précisément à aucune des
questions enfin on y reviendra
totalement mais on peut après un
inventaire fastidieux à la prévert
c'est juste de dire que quand on
raisonne avec quelques faits enfin
apprendre à quelques règles simples je
le redis des calculs d'or de grandeur je
vous en donner un juste après la loi de
conservation de l'énergie l'énergie doit
bien sortir de quelque part plus est les
diffuse plus elle est coûteuse et c'est
pas une question de taille de réservoir
c'est une question de capacité de
facilité à l'extraire de l'environnement
et une fois que vous avez ces grandes
règles
vous êtes capable globalement de
commencer à vous y retrouver un peu dans
toute cette affaire pour que
l'électricité et voiture électrique
c'est pareil l'électricité il y en a pas
dans la nature
sauf à brancher directement les voitures
sur les éclairs d'orage
ce qu'on ne sait pas faire pour le
moment et donc on l'a fait avec autre
chose et donc l'électricité est une
aussi bonne manière que la façon de la
produire et d'une aussi bonne idée par
donc la façon de la produire pas mieux
et
pas moins bien alors un petit calcul
d'ordre de grandeur juste pour finir
là-dessus je me suis amusé c'est un truc
que je viens de mettre en ligne sur mon
site à faire une comparaison des
capitaux qui sont nécessaires pour
fournir l'électricité
un pays comme la france mais en fait ce
n'est pas une affaire de quantité j'ai
fait une comparaison entre si on a le
système actuel que je qualifie en
première approximation de tout nucléaire
et si on a un système qui est basé
totalement sûre d énergie que sont
l'éolien ou le solaire qui sont pas
toutes les nerfs parce que
l'hydroélectricité qui est la première
électricité d'origine renouvelable dans
le monde s'est fortement développé parce
que comme le pétrole c'est une énergie
concentrée les vallées d'altitude
permettre de concentrer l'eau et donc on
retombe sur quelque chose de concentré
pilotable et ça c'est qu'on sait
concurrentiel avec les énergies fossiles
mais si je prends que l'éolien ou du
solaire vous avez un rapport en gros
d'un facteur 10 entre donc il faut
investir dix fois plus d'argent pour
avoir un système qui est 100% éolien
plus stockage ou 100% sur barrage
réversible un pas sur batterie parce que
si c'est sur batterie vous rajoutez
plutôt un facteur 50
donc ce genre de raisonnement
ça vous permet de faire le tri très très
vite contre une politique publique qui a
une chance d'arriver à ses fins et une
politique publique pour laquelle vous
pouvez parier toutes vos économies sur
le fait qu'on n'y arrivera jamais ce qui
peut avoir un intérêt pour votre
patrimoine propre
[Musique]
merci